joining me now professor christina pagel
who's professor of operational research
at university college london and a
member of the independent sage committee
um so what what do you think is the key
thing that we've learned from these
figures this morning
i mean
to me what really stands out is
obviously 133 000 excess deaths is
a lot of people who died who in without
the pandemic likely wouldn't have died
um but we've actually had if we look at
covered on the death certificate almost
190 000 deaths over that time period
um and what we have seen in the last few
years is we haven't had a flu season
um and actually in that sense excess
deaths is kind of you're kind of seeing
more deaths from covid but far fewer
deaths from um flu and ammonia than we
would normally see and so it's kind of a
weird measure to use in that way it's
kind of giving you a very big picture
without really kind of digging in to the
details and we're seeing as your
correspondence said the kind of the
deaths from
how people have reacted to lockdown
about not being able to access care and
potentially you know more deaths from
heart disease and diabetes
but in terms of those 190 000 excess
deaths from with covered on the death
certificate i mean how if you were to
balance that up against the number of
deaths that we we didn't have through
things like flu and things like that
what would be the difference do you
think
well we normally have um somewhere
between 10 and 20 000 deaths a year from
flu or pneumonia and we just haven't
seen that over the last few years um and
it's not that you know they're dying
from covered instead it's that the
measures we took to control covid also
controlled flu and pneumonias and other
respiratory diseases because people just
weren't mixing as much and so if you
don't mix you don't get sick from all
kinds of things and you also don't get
exposed to things like you know car
accidents and that kind of thing so
we've seen fewer deaths because of the
things we were doing to control covid
but of course if you if you would say
put that as your biggest estimate as 20
000 and say there's 20 000 lives that
have been saved um
potentially because we were doing that
that's still 170 000 excess deaths isn't
it it's still
an awfully large number there's nothing
good about that number nothing nothing
good at all and you know i hope that
you know especially as we move into
thinking about the covenant inquiry that
we don't forget
um the
enormous toll that clover has taken on
our population um
and not just you know the people who
died but the families that are left
behind you know i think there are
estimates that maybe about between nine
and twelve thousand children have lost a
close family member i mean that that's a
really big impact on people absolutely
um hospital admissions though
you say that they are the best way uh to
compare
the different waves and where we are now
i mean when you look at the numbers now
anecdotally it seems that so many of us
know somebody who who has covert at the
moment we seem to be
in another wave but but that's not
reflecting through in hospital
admissions is it
well hospital emissions are going up and
they've all made up they've almost
doubled since the beginning of march
scotland today has more people in
hospital with covered than they've had
throughout the whole pandemic now some
of those will be
people who aren't there because they
have covert they're there for other
reasons and just happen to have covered
but we're still seeing increases in
people who need hospital for covid and
we're also in a situation where our most
vulnerable people the elderly um are now
you know almost six months out of their
booster and we know that the boosters
are waning and so ons last week said
that you know almost four percent of
over 70s have coveted right now and so
that will create more pressure on
hospitals hospitals are still seeing you
know the longest weights fraying need
that they've had we're still seeing more
people more nhs staff off sick because
of covid and so in a situation where the
nhs is actually really squeezed and we
are seeing an increased pressure from
people with covid even though on an
individual level you're less likely to
team hospital than you were a year ago
so how do you feel about the fact that
all of the restrictions have been lifted
do you wish that we'd still had a
certain number of them in place and that
perhaps you know everybody seems to have
flung their masks in the bin now don't
they
well i haven't
but
uh
it feels very odd to me because you know
we saw in december we had a really
massive spike when omicron first came
here and people did change their
behaviors people were testing more
people reduced their contact we also had
plan b measures so masters and working
from home in january and cases did come
down but they're now going up again
they're going up again really fast and
it's quite likely that we're going to
get to at least the same peak that we
were in december if not higher like it
already is in scotland
um
and it feels like no one
kind of even knows let alone is doing
anything about it i mean the chances of
someone getting covered now are pretty
high
um
and it just it just makes me think you
know it's been less than three months
since the last wave
um and you know is this our future that
people are gonna get sick every two
three months and that's going to have a
big burden on the economy as people
can't work and some people will get long
covered and some people will need
hospital and die and i kind of feel like
we do need to talk about what it means
when we keep having these waves
of new variants coming through
but what is the solution i mean people
don't obviously like wearing masks or or
isolating and keeping their distance or
working from home
it it seems unfeasible that people will
continue to take over the precautions
forever
um i do think that there is a discussion
to be had about work i know obviously um
not everybody can work from home many
people can't but i think for people who
can there is now moved to hybrid working
where you spend some days in the office
and some days at home
i think that the really long term thing
we have to do is think about ventilation
and fresh air because the one thing that
we have learned is that if you're
outside
you're a much much lower risk of
catching cobia so if we can make the
indoor environment more like outside
then we will reduce transmission and
there's no doubt about that right and we
know how to do that but it requires a
will and it's not something we can do as
individuals it's something that requires
the state to support businesses and
public services to improve indoor air
quality
okay professor christina pagel um good
to talk to you thanks so much for giving
us your thoughts on these figures